so our next speaker is Fiamma strani Oh
fiamma's a tenured scientists at the
woods hole oceanographic institution and
her research focuses on polar oceans in
their role in climate and climate
variability most of fiamma's recent work
is motivated by the rapid loss of the
Greenland ice sheet and is aimed at
understanding the interaction between
the ice sheets and the ocean and one of
the findings for which Fiamma is most
well-known is showing the contact
between the warm waters that originated
in the tropics and the margins of
Greenland's glaciers and today Fiamma is
going to tell us about North Atlantic
warming and the retreat of greens
Greenland's glaciers thank you thank you
and thank you for this great workshop so
I'm going to pop back into the present
and you already gave away my punchline
so we're going to make this short so I
and a group of colleagues have been
spending the last few years looking at
Greenland and I'm not a glaciologist so
whenever I say anything about glaciers
and ice sheets you know you can question
me I have an oceanographer but we've
been working with a lot of glaciologist
and paleoclimatologist and some
atmospheric scientists to try and
understand the really intrinsically
coupled system at the margins of the
Greenland ice sheet where really the
atmosphere the ocean the sea ice and the
glaciers are coming together and it's a
pretty complex system and the gist of
this talk is we're making progress but
it's slow and it's a wonderful fantastic
system to study because you can keep
adding layers of complexity so there's
big ice in Greenland right Dennis was
just talking about ridges when they're
big they're five meters and so on some
of these icebergs that we're dealing
with and some of these glaciers are
grounded in a thousand or 600 meters of
water and I'll show you what that's that
can
to our instruments in a little bit so
why are we interested well the Greenland
ice sheet is changing rather quickly and
so what I'm showing here are some
measurements from the grace satellite
the curve on the right is a time series
the units are gigatonnes just over the
last decade or so and and ultimately it
goes down so Greenland its losing mass
this is the gravity measurement so this
is an actual total mass loss with a lot
of caveats for the interpretation but
the point I want to make is that the
rate of ice loss is increasing its
anywhere but steady and the really
extreme 2012 melt event you can look at
the blips that Jennifer was talking
about it really stands out and where is
Greenland losing mass well its losing
mass that's the map on the left along
its marine margins and especially in
southeast and western Greenland and just
to put some numbers in context over the
last two decades mass loss from
Greenland quadrupled it contributed
about seven and a half millimeters of
sea level rise from Greenland alone it's
now that's about double the entire tech
contribution at right now Greenland
alone accounts for about a quarter of
global sea level rise so that's one
reason to care for it the other reason
is is the large freshwater input into
the North Atlantic so we're used to
thinking of the Arctic Ocean and Arctic
sea ice export as d major player in
fresh water changes in the North
Atlantic over the Kadel centennial time
scales and but but Greenland is ramping
up so the cumulative anomalous fresh
water discharge over the last 20 years
is about a third of the size of the
great salinity anomalies which are
periodic sort of fresh anomalies coming
out from the Arctic which we know have
disrupted dense water information
over the instrumental record so how does
an ice sheet loose mass well there's two
ways if an ice sheet is is in balance
it's a schematic on the left you get net
precipitation usually in the form of
snow in the winter and then you have
surface smelt plus discharge of icebergs
at the marine margins and if these are
in balance the ice sheet is steady and
what's been happening over the last few
decades is that both what I'm I circled
in blue the iceberg mass loss the
dynamic mass loss as well as the surface
mass balance so the net surface melt
have been negative meaning they've
contributed to mass loss and so to see
if I can see ya so the blue is a curve
so we have a mixture here of
observations and models to reconstruct
variability and we can really only go
back about fifty years and so what I'm
showing here in the blue is the ice
discharge and so it's been increasing
especially since the mid-1990s these are
I'll show you what it means in a minute
but it is associated with iceberg
production and prior to the end and at
the same time the red curve is a surface
mass balance so you can see that there's
some fluctuations but ultimately over
the last two decades it's really been
going down and so how do we do in models
because ultimately we'd like to
understand what's going on we also want
to predict what's happening and so
models are doing an okay job at
predicting changes in surface mass
balance if you warm the atmosphere as
the climate models predict and you
couple it with an ice sheet model you
can actually reproduce pretty well the
past surface mass balance changes what
we aren't able to reproduce very well is
the dynamic ice loss so the speed up of
glaciers the increase in iceberg
discharge in the 2007 IPCC report
dynamic mass loss was not even present
in any of the estimates
it was deemed as the largest and
certainty and sea level rise predictions
in the last IPCC report it's a little
bit present but really it's a mechanism
that we don't understand well enough to
put in models and the dynamic ice models
I mean I sheet models are still not
fully coupled and and really there was a
lot of tension in the community for not
wanting to even put them in because
nobody most people feel we don't
understand the dynamics well enough to
include them so in practice what are we
talking about so I said Greenland is
losing mass over the edges while it's
happening primarily through ice
discharge in fjords such as the one I'm
showing in the middle and through the
retreat of large glaciers like this one
and so this is how Heim blazer in South
East Greenland in this little box here
and you can see in 2001 it was here
2003-2006 and so this is just an example
of one of Greenland's largest glaciers
which over a few years pinned by about
200 meters at its terminus retreated
about seven kilometres and doubled its
flow rate so this is the increased
iceberg production this is the dynamic
mass loss and it's been occurring all
around marine terminating glaciers in
Greenland so to put Greenland in a
climatic context overlaid on the map of
Greenland here I'm showing this dynamic
thinning and again it's all at the
boundaries and I superimposed it on a
schematic of the ocean circulation
because this is really one of the the
key contributors to the climate around
Greenland so what I'm showing here is
the path of the warm Atlantic water so
the Gulf Stream in red turns into the
North Atlantic Current and one of the
big differences between Greenland and
Antarctica is that Greenland is
connected to the tropical oceans
effectively through a system of ridges
and so if you're an ocean current warm
waters like to flow along topography and
so what what you see here is pathways of
warm water sneaking up the ridge that
connect Scotland to Greenland with
Iceland in the middle and so through
this pathway you have some of the
warmest waters hugging the coast of
Greenland the water is here offshore at
12 degrees Celsius that's very warm you
have another pathway of Atlantic waters
going into the Nordic seeds there's a
return flow and and the waters here or
maybe 12 degrees warm then there's a
path that goes into the Arctic Ocean
it's Dennis show the circulation it goes
all the way around the Arctic Ocean it
gets transformed comes back out some of
it flew flow through narrow strait this
is the coldest part of ocean around
Greenland and then you have Baffin Bay
Baffin Bay on the west side of Greenland
is really an extension of the Cipolla
region where the warmest waters are and
so Greenland has access to some very
warm waters offshore but they're not
impinging on the coast of Greenland
because we have what I've drawn here in
blue these this is a fresh cold current
from the Arctic Ocean and so this cold
current is is sort of protecting the
coast and the margins of Greenland from
the warm waters and so it's the
interplay of these two currents that has
sets a lot of the climate of grilling
greenlanders I'm going to argue in a
minute and so why do we care about the
ocean well at the same time as the ice
sheets started changing this is the same
plot i showed you before we have records
that the ocean around Greenland started
warming and in fact that present the
North Atlantic especially the cipolla
region is the warmest on record and my
record is about 50 years long okay so 50
years is where we have a record of
subsurface ocean temperatures so I can
tell you that the upper ocean the top
500 700 meters that's the blue curve
shown here are at the warmest they've
been from direct measurements right now
if we go back in time from direct ocean
measurements we can use sea surface
temperature measurements we can get to
about a hundred years with those and
what these show is still did at around
the Greenland margins we have the
warmest surface temperatures right now
they also tell us that there was a
period in the 1930s when the cipolla
region was almost as warm and in fact
there's very little direct evidence of
what the glaciers were doing in the
1930s it's mostly fruit photographic
reconstructions but there are
indications that the glaciers retreated
in the 1930s too and so what's happening
in Greenland well what we want to
understand is is effectively what is
happening to the glaciers and what what
I'm showing here is a schematic where
I've grouped together in read all of the
mechanisms that have been proposed to
explain the retreat's of the glacis and
so if we go from the left this is a
Tidewater glacier so it's grounded in
maybe six seven hundred meters the
largest glaciers in Greenland are also
the largest contributors to the dynamic
mass loss you can explain about sixty or
seventy percent with about fifteen
Blazers so so it's it's the big guys
that are playing a big role and so we
have increased surface warming and
melting as a driver a lot of this has to
do with structural changes in in the
glacier dynamics the lubrication
hypothesis was a really big hypothesis
until about it decade five years or so
ago now evidence is emerging that it
can't really explain the acceleration
but it probably still plays a big role
then we have increased submarine melting
at the marine margins so the ocean
waters contain enough heat to drive
melting at the base of the glaciers and
if you can extract that heat you can
drive you can essentially melt the
underside of the glacier you can cause
it to live
up and then it can slide faster so
changes it's not that you are melting
the Glazers at the edges you are
changing the boundary condition at the
edges and allowing them to flow faster
which leads to more carving and more
mass loss and then there are the years
that changes in the sea ice and ice berg
mixture at the edge of the glacier is
also another driver of variability so
this is great let's go out and test this
because really all of these mechanisms
they're not in the glacier models we
don't have ocean models that resolve the
fjords or the Shelf to very high
accuracy for that matter with with a few
regional exceptions and so one of the
hypotheses which is one of the leading
hypothesis to explain the changes in
Greenland is well the ocean warmed it
increased melting at the underside of
the glaciers and therefore the glaciers
sped up the problem is we we really have
no means of testing this hypothesis and
we have no models that can resolve the
coupled system and so this is something
that we've been working on for a few
years and I i want to show you just a
short time lapse movie to give you an
idea of what it means to be working at
the edges of Greenland's glaciers so
this is how I glacier at south east
greenland and this is about a free hour
condensed a movie of a bulletin that
didn't work and strike and
so this glacier is about five kilometers
across about 600 meters deep and and
this is floating ice that you're seeing
that's the glacier and this is one of
the big carving events that happens
throughout the summer and ideally this
is where you'd like to make the
measurements ideally this is the region
that you'd like to model and there's
some obvious complexity associated with
doing this so what I'm going to show you
now it's some of the measurements that
we've been making that are just an
excuse to sort of show some of the
advances that I think we've made not
just my group it as a community so I've
been working along in a lot in this
glacier at the margin of this glacier
that I just showed you and and the map
in the Middle shows a typical survey
that will go out and make in the summer
the orange dots are locations where
we'll lower in instruments the blue our
locations well we'll put some more than
store entation the green is is where
we're trying to get where the ship can't
get and so to give you an idea of
measurements we use some ad hoc vessels
like like green peach ships when the
Russians don't take them away local
Greenlandic vessels and so we take
measurements and of course these are
snapshots we're there in the summer it's
the only time we can get there and and
they give us an idea of what's happening
we're also crawling closer where we
don't need there to go we work from
helicopters and we work with a number of
autonomous vehicles under water and
surface so this is sending vehicles
where you don't want to go and so so
this is just an example of what water is
outside of these fjords look like and so
the panel on the bottom to the right
shows the cold fresh Arctic water that's
banked up against the shelf and the warm
salty atlantic water underneath and so
we know from surveys on the shell
that we have this layering of cold fresh
Arctic waters around Greenland up to
about 200 meters death and then warm
Atlantic waters underneath and the
Atlantic waters are climbing up in these
troughs that were scoured in the last
glacial maximum or before by the ice
streams themselves if we go in the
fjords what we see is the same layering
of water masses so this is just a
long-feared section of temperature in
this furor that the edge of Helheim
blades there the last few profiles are
from expendable instruments deployed
through helicopter and what you see is
some pretty warm waters at depth all the
way up to the glacier at least as close
as we can get and so we can document
that in the summer these waters are
there to understand their circulation
and their variability we've been using a
number of instruments some are
occasional like tagged seals which will
dive and give you records of properties
on the shelf and in the fjords we've
also been putting a lot of morred
instrumentation we're there in the
summer as all of you know from working
in the high latitudes there is a lot of
seasonal and high frequency variability
you cannot do a summer survey and hope
to have resolved everything and and so
the big problem with Greenland is is
that you want to make measurements in
the upper part of the water column you
want to see how the Atlantic and the
polar water interact where their
boundaries that but that happens to be
exactly where the icebergs are drifting
and and so sometimes we win but
sometimes we lose and this is an example
of a morning that was hit by an iceberg
that pushed the sphere which was happily
sitting at about 250 meters all the way
down to 500 where it imploded and it
took a while to get it back but so so
what do we found what we can now we're
starting to have a record at least in
one field of some of the
interannual variability and this is just
a record from the middle of the fjord
and so you see the really alternation of
seasonally in the upper layer of cold
water progressively warming there's a
lot of variability down below there's a
very rich dynamics so we're starting to
have a short record from the fjord we
have records from the shelf again it
might seem strange from all of you but
the shelves around Greenland are very
difficult to instrument in part because
of the icebergs difficult to get there
we don't know the symmetry so records
such as these to give you a measure of
the variability are reading you and then
we can look farther out we're trying to
establish the connection between changes
in the Cipolla North Atlantic and what's
happening in the fjords to test this
hypothesis and so what we've been doing
is using these Argo profiles is about
three thousand Argo floats at any given
time distributed around the world ocean
they profile park around 1,500 meters
come up after week profile again come to
the surface transmit their profile go
back down and they're drifting along and
so you can take for southeast green
dollar for example all those black dots
are profiles since 2008 actually since
well there have been running since 2002
so you can reconstruct the variability
in the large-scale ocean in the vicinity
of Greenland and we've done that and the
reason to do all of this is to produce
something like this so this is a figure
that is trying to ask a really basic
question do we see the same variability
in the fjords as we see in the
large-scale ocean and the answer is with
the evidence yes to some extent so the
blue is the fjords upper 500 meters the
red is the armiger's see those are go
profiles and and no the red is the shelf
and and the black is the Omega C and so
what you see is is really the same
seasonal and to some extent interannual
variability
with some caveats and you can see a warm
period warm year in 2011 and so on and
these records are really important in
the sense that they demonstrate a link
which right now we don't have the models
to demonstrate and they're really
important to understand if we want to
provide boundary conditions to glace
your models Ice Sheet models this this
is the kind of understanding that we
need to get it and so one of the hopes
is is to be able to maintain some of
these records for a decade or longer and
ultimately one of the results here
though is that we've documented that
when you do change things in the Cipolla
North Atlantic change this change
propagates very quickly to the margins
of Greenland and I I can tell you more
about the mechanisms through this for
which this happens but but not now so
the other thing I thought I'd mention is
can we look into the past a little bit
there's a lot of people here with
interest beyond the fifty or six or
four-year time series that i just showed
and so this is some work that we've been
doing with Danish colleagues in the same
fjords that we've been collecting
sediment courts and the idea here is
that you can collect sediment cores on
the shelf and for example reconstruct
the water temperature from various
proxies what we were interested in is
not so much reconstructing the water
temperatures but actually building a
record of glacier variability on any
time scale we fought possible and so the
basic idea here is that when a glacier
retreats it calves a lot more and
icebergs as as Dennis mentioned as all
of you know carry a large sediment load
ice rafter debris now in the fjords the
cementation rates are huge but you can
essentially collect cords and
reconstruct the sand
deposition flux sand flux sand
depositions that what they call it yeah
and you know for me as a physical
oceanographer all I understand is when
the glacier retreats caused a lot of
icebergs I get a much higher San
deposition rate in periods when the
glacier isn't carving and it's slowly
expanding the sand deposition rate down
in the fjord is much less and so what
the paleo climatologists I've been
working with did is they we went out we
collected sediment cores and then
through various datings and and
reconstructions they came up with a time
series of deposition in about mid for
this particular fewer then that's the
curve shown in black and then we wanted
to check whether this was actually an
indicator of what the glacier was doing
and so we used his startled photographs
reconstruction of terminus position for
the glacier up there so these are the
red dots and there's relatively good
agreement and so what we see from this
record which only goes back about a
hundred years is that a present we have
a high deposition rate in agreement with
the fact that these glaciers are
retreating there's a lot of iceberg
production we had a similar high carving
rate in at the end of the nineteen
thirties 1940 we also see a lot of
higher frequency variability and so what
we did then if we took this record and
asked some really basic questions of how
it correlated with some of the potential
drivers of placer variability and and so
we've compared it with essentially a
number of indices the red star we have a
time series that goes back about a
hundred years of sea surface
temperatures off of Iceland that's the
Atlantic water source the blue star we
have a record of sea ice extent which is
has been correlated with Arctic sea ice
arctic freshwater export coming out of
the Arctic through Fram Strait
we've combined them into a shelf index
the right now they're just sort of
equally Wade which is meant to take into
account that the margins of Greenland
are integrating Atlantic and Arctic
variability and then we compared them
with some of the other modes of
variability that or indices of
variability that we think play a role in
this area so the nao you've heard about
we have air temperature measurements and
the Atlantic multidecadal oscillation
when you do this you know you get a map
and you can look at periods and I'm
going to not spend a lot of time here
but essentially what we found is that on
Long multidecadal timescales we can see
in the record from this particular
glacier reconstruction that the glacier
is following the multi de kado
variability and and it makes sense the
ocean and the atmosphere are in sync in
this region over multi-decade of time
scales the glacier is carving more when
the weather is warm the ocean it's warm
if we subtract the multi decato
variability though we can actually see
an impact of the ocean variability and
so we can see that periods when if you
read those GSA's are periods from the
Arctic where large freshwater anomalies
came through this tends to cool the
coast of Greenland and and and you get
cooler climate the glacier wasn't
retreating as much or was advancing and
then you have peaks in Atlantic warming
the glacier is responding to these two
and so again we don't we can't prove
anything but this is building evidence
that the ocean variability and the
combined Arctic and Atlantic variability
are playing a role in the glacier it for
at least this gracer in South East
Greenland and this is really the same
thought so okay
so it's a quick summary slide that we've
really made I would argue a lot of
progress in understanding how the wiring
of the glaciers and the ice streams in
Greenland the wiring of this climate
component with the ocean and the
atmosphere and it's it's a very complex
wiring one of the things that we found
is that submarine melting for example at
the edge of the glaciers depends equally
on having warmer water available but
also on having a lot of surface melt
available when you get increased surface
melt at the top of the ice sheets a lot
of this water drains to the base of the
glaces 600 meters it drives it's very
turbulent flow which is the mean which
which really increases the ability of
the ocean to drive melting so in this
recent period more surface melting means
more submarine melting too and so this
is an example of how complex the climate
dynamics at the marine margins that the
glaciers are and it's it's it's great
because it's it's very fascinating and
fun to study and a lot more work needs
to be done and I I'd like to show this
figure just to conclude so this is North
East Greenland now I've mostly talked
about glaciers with mostly vertical
faces they've lost any floating part
because they're moving so quickly this
is a glacier in North East Greenland the
short name is the 79 North glacier it's
almost in fram strait and it has
Greenland's largest floating ice tongue
left it's about 80 kilometers long Peter
and used to be largest but it's been
losing pieces so quickly that now this
one wins and we we have the opportunity
here to study a system that is evolving
but it's it's a very challenging system
there's indications that it's finning
now this glacier doesn't car very much
and so here the ocean role is really by
driving melting just as in Antarctica
under these big ice shelves and and
finning this floating ice tongue until
it lifts enough that it will start to
carve and melt and but the challenges
are huge so we were there in 2009 and
managed to get some of the first
measurements through the floating ice
time so what you're seeing here is the
floating ice time where there's a crack
in the middle whether sea ice has where
sea ice is formed and so you know we
were able to land with a helicopter
drill a little hole get about 5 profiles
and to this day they're the only
profiles from under this i stunk and and
i always tell students this is a good
analogy of the challenges here we have
measurements from one summer in one
small location over a huge area and
that's it we haven't been able to go
back but this there's a lot of work to
be done to understand these systems okay
I'm going to finish here